free agency is due to start on Monday I
know Wednesday is technically when the
new league year begins but free agency
as a practical matter starts on Monday
that's when right at 12 o'clock Eastern
we will start hearing about offers it to
be made to players tentative agreements
that can't become final until 4:00 p.m.
Eastern on Wednesday that's when it all
starts and that's just four days away
and think of how much the world has
changed in the last four days four days
from now what will our national mood be
what will people be doing is they adjust
to a dramatically altered routine for
most people where schools are closed
where people aren't at work where people
are either working at home are not
working at all and people are worrying
about where they're gonna get their
money where the average football fans
life has been thrown into disarray
compare that to constant reports of
football players agreeing to terms on
multi multi multi-million dollar
contracts awkward optics I think so the
league doesn't Adam Schefter of ESPN
says the league has no plans to delay
the start of the league year which means
free agency starts next week offers
start Monday signings start Wednesday
now you're not gonna have any visits in
most cases the big-money deals were done
before there's a visit anyway remember
what happened with Brock Osweiler in
Houston they agreed to terms he went and
signed the deal and in time they
realized both sides hated each other
that will happen now in to the extent
that Tom Brady was thinking about taking
visits is he really gonna do that now
some people may slip into wherever it is
that he's living now in the offseason
and visit him but these things are all
gonna proceed unless the NFL changes its
plans the key words in that phrase no
plans to delay the start of the league
year last week when the NFL PA set up a
cba voting process that continued beyond
the window for applying the franchise
tag or the transition tag the NFL told
me they had no plans to move that
deadline when they eventually did so no
plans means plans can change right now
no plans I think they want to get
through this period of time where
they're figuring out what to do about
the league meetings up
newsflash they're not going to happen
and then what they're gonna do about the
draft but ultimately look they've got
full flexibility to do whatever they
want with the start of free agency and I
point to 2011 the lockout a labor
dispute a garden-variety labor dispute
the players are locked out happens all
the time in a union setting so free
agency doesn't happen until there's a
new CBA there's a new CBI signed early
August and free agency happens then
months after the draft months after it
was supposed to happen if the NFL can
delay free agency from months as part of
a fairly ordinary work stoppage why
can't it delay the start a free agency
in the midst of extremely extraordinary
times and I'm hoping that this is just
part of that working the the the the the
reality through people's brains you know
I think eventually for example March
Madness is gonna be canceled whether you
want it or not whether you agree with it
or not whatever the case may be it's
gonna be cancelled once the NBA pulled
the plug
March Madness was done and we're seeing
these conferences gradually come to
grips with the fact that they can't have
a tournament and the Big East actually
started playing games and at halftime
somebody came to their senses and said
we can't do this so I think as the NFL
gets closer and closer to Monday there's
gonna be an adult in the room that says
we can't proceed with free agency and
I've seen the cynical view on Twitter
that ho-ho-hoo there's no other sports
this week we're gonna dominate I first
of all I'm not sure people are gonna
care and second of all as optics go this
one folks is right up there with Pete
Rozelle deciding to play games just a
couple of days after Kennedy was shot
and I know there's a difference between
games and non game transactions but free
agency has become one of the major
offseason attractions for the National
Football League so to have that all play
out at a time when average people are
trying to understand how their lives are
going to be impacted not just by the
fear of coronavirus infecting their
families and maybe killing their elderly
and infirm but also their jobs drying up
their savings being wiped out how many
we hear the average American is just one
or two paychecks away from having
nothing that's gonna be tested for
millions of families should we really be
engaging in this spending free-for-all
this prime example of American access at
a time when average men and women aren't
really sure how their lives are gonna be
a couple of months from now that's my
take on it you may agree you may
disagree but I think the smart move for
the NFL is to delay the start of free
agency the smart move for the NFL is to
be flexible here and to be open and
transparent I understand they're trying
to figure out what they do before they
tell us what they're gonna do but how
many times they're gonna say that
they're closely monitoring the situation
before they give us something
substantive and the time for being ahead
of the curve is past the NFL is playing
catch-up now and I understand they're
their sport isn't in season but even
when it's the offseason it's still NFL
season I mean you can't act like you are
the dominant 12 month a year sport which
they are and then put their head in the
ground under the guise of well we're not
playing games now well no but you still
have events that people care about
League meetings free agency draft what
are you going to do people want to know
and also it's an opportunity to the
extent there's anyone out there that
isn't taking this seriously
if they're an ardent NFL fan and they
see NFL postponing the draft or moving
the draft indoors or otherwise taking
dramatic action in the face of the
coronavirus maybe somebody who would be
inclined to say it's just the flu we'll
start to look around and realize it's
more than just the flu it's about
limiting the spread so it doesn't kill
people and it's about limiting the
spread so our healthcare facilities
aren't overrun by sick people who need
treatment so if you have a heart attack
if you are in a car accident if you need
an appendectomy if you are about to give
birth or your spouse is about to give
birth there will be appropriate
accommodations at the hospital because
they won't be constantly dealing with a
flood of people who are trying to get
urgent care so that they don't dive
the coronavirus it's that simple so my
point continues to be this the NFL needs
to show leadership and I think the NFL
needs to be thinking long term big
picture what's right what's wrong
I personally believe it's right to delay
the start of free agency it's right if
necessary to delay the draft they've got
a lot of time to work with and they were
willing to create a major inconvenience
for all teams nine years ago in the
guise of winning a labor dispute by
having the draft in April and free
agency later if you're willing to take
extraordinary steps in a fairly ordinary
labor dispute you should be willing to
take extraordinary steps when we have
found ourselves in extraordinary times
or more accurately the extraordinary
times have found us
[Music]
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports